so Melissa before we start I just want
to say that the first time we came here
it was eight years ago we were in a tiny
little room somewhere in comic-con and
nobody knew who we were
the first season hadn't even aired and I
think there were 20 people there we
showed the first ten minutes of our
pilot and now we're in Hall H how does
that feel Tyler yeah this is the coolest
so we want to thank Comic Con and all
the fans at Comic Con first for making
us feel so special here yeah thank you
guys this is the this is the coolest
thing ever comic-con is the greatest
thing to do as a group of friends and
co-workers and you guys make it so cool
for us we're not worthy we don't deserve
you guys thank you so much all right so
take it away Melissa all right
so first question 100 episodes is a
rarity for shows like ours so this is -
Tyler Dylan and Linton what was it like
going from the pilot to the 100th
episode that journey what was it like
for you I know right it was it was a
blip a little bit 18 I was 8 we were 18
when we got started on the show and
we're like we're adults now right 25
that's an adult we're grown-ass man and
it's really emotional for me and the
only time it ever really gets emotional
for me is when I like talk about it like
this or or when I see something really
sentimental like over the years they put
together this little trailer that just
showed every single promotion like promo
that we did for the show and it's just
since I was there for every single one
of them it's just it's it's hard to
explain how how close this show is to my
heart and how close everybody here is to
me and they you know they make me
happier and they saved my life and they
just show me that like you know love is
alive and they're all so incredibly
talented every single one of them every
single person here
and Jeff thank you for giving us this
this the coolest opportunity ever man I
mean we're the best buds ever and and
this wouldn't have been possible without
you and I'll tell one little story about
you on 100th episode of a show and it is
amazing for our show to have 100
episodes I didn't I never thought that a
show called Teen Wolf would get to 100
episodes but when we were cutting the
cake you do a cake when you get a
hundred episodes and we had the knife
brought over all of our cast and crew
were there and Tyler hands me the knife
and says cut the cake Jeff and I said
Tyler you're the only one who's been in
all 100 episodes and I handed the knife
back to him it was his cake to cut might
by the way my goal here is to make Tyler
weep to really make him cry it's
happening so throwing that question
Dylan what's it like to have gone from
the pilot where we were freezing our
asses off in Georgia - here - 100
episodes yeah I mean I I gotta echo what
Tyler said you know it's just been it's
nothing but emotional now that it's over
and you know for me this this will
always be such a special thing for me
and you know this was my first part ever
I still remembered you know like getting
the call for my manager that I got the
part of Stiles you know in my little
apartment and Wes with my buddies and I
was gonna be going out to shoot this
pilot and entering this whole new you
know phase in my life and or I you know
I didn't even know that at the time I
just I got a job and um the fact that it
made you know seven years later with 20
we're 25 we just finished
it's just amazing and it's an amazing
group of people and it so it's just been
a family and it'll always be a family
and I'll always miss this character and
the show and so you know it's it's just
it's amazing you know so it's sad it's
sad it makes me super emotional I'm
getting shaky right now even talking
about it Melissa you weren't you weren't
there on our initial pilot presentation
but you're in the pile
so the questions for you - oh it's been
life-changing and amazing and
spectacular and sad and every emotion
that you could possibly feel you know I
feel like it's I think every time you
we're asked we always say we're friends
and we're family and we can pick up
whenever time has left off and that's
just a beautiful thing there hasn't been
many dust-ups and we're very thankful
for that and it's just been it's it's
been second it feels like it's been
seconds what can I say I'm like feel
like we're going down I feel like we're
going down to bring this back up no all
right let's uh this season we had a lot
of characters who came back to beacon
hills Charlie what was it like coming
back oh man I mean I'm lucky that my
character didn't die you know the saying
is that nobody ever dies on Teen Wolf
but I was definitely grateful to have
run off to wherever I went to as Ethan
coming back I mean to kind of echo what
you all just said it is such a great set
I've been lucky to be on different sets
and every job has its virtues but this
is a family so I know I know you all
know that heckling is coming back
Colton's coming back from other people
coming back we all talk to each other
and we were like we have to go back and
we have to make sure that we do
something great for the fans and
something that we get to do for fun so
it's a blast I can't wait for you guys
to see these next 10 episodes because
it's I think when you know a show is
gonna end you give it your all and
everybody's all in so it's it's a it's a
good ride alright so I get to ask the
next question this one's for Shelley
Shelley you came in on with us during
season three and I want to know your
characters been in many many episodes
has your character ended up without
giving away too many
where you think it would have ended up
and is it the right ending for Malia
predicted Dillon Malia winds up with
Scott maybe be careful here cuz somebody
from the audience is gonna throw
something at my head no do they wind up
together I don't know but we you do see
us in the shower in the trailer so we'll
see what happens but you know I think
the hardest part for Malia her biggest
challenge was fitting into the pack and
Stiles's character was very instrumental
as you know to help Malia get into that
pack and behave so to see the trajectory
of Malia it's fun as an actor to play
but I don't I don't think I would have
predicted I wouldn't predicted this but
I also didn't predict that I'd stay on
the show for this many seasons yeah and
you keep you keep me there so I've been
very very blessed for that i sat Dylan
Sprayberry next to me so I could make
him talk something dude Oh what saved up
D first of all did you did Liam end up
where you think he'd end up is it a good
ending for Liam's character were you
happy with your death scene we're really
good in it every dancing yeah someone
kicked me in the nuts and the death
scene so that wasn't nice but someone
kicked you in yeah my death scene sorry
do you do you remember coming in to
audition I do yeah is that what question
is it's gonna be okay what was it was
the question what was it like to
audition yeah auditioning was really
really fun because you auditioned for a
different role yeah
the young Derek thing which I I think I
had like what four auditions for that or
something yes it was like it was funny
because I had like a lot of auditions
for that character which I didn't get
and then I came in once for Liam and got
that
do you remember auditioning with these
two boys I do I remember like I remember
walking into the parking lot like with
my grandma I think with Grandma rose and
I saw Dylan I think in the parking lot
walking in and then I saw Tyler in the
kitchen and then we all we all talked
about skateboarding and stuff and then
went an audition and I was really
nervous but were they good to you they
were good to me we talked a lot before
which made me a lot less nervous I
remember some of this I was actually
have video evidence of some of this I
actually want to see no yes
and speaking of scenes I've got a
question for Kyla and Sprayberry
do you guys have a favorite scene that
you have done together there's a couple
though there's a lot all of my scenes
all of the scenes that we film together
are great I think remember that video
game scene we did in season 4 the first
one yeah the first one we got another
one though the one coming up and one
coming up was is is dope I think that's
a good one you guys are guys got you
ready for love um I think right off the
bat like running with a real-life wolf
oh guy that cause like that was the
first time I ever did like any action
thing with Teen Wolf and I was so stoked
and I got to do it with this guy with
the real wolf - yeah like they fed him
meat like the wolf was not a dog or a
dog and they held him with a chain like
it was a wolf
they had a chain not even a leash train
rusted chain yeah and he's seen with
this guy's all right I got another
question guy I got a Cody question yeah
I want to make sure we get everyone to
answer here Cody
you have a favorite Theo scene and she
do you think Malia and Theo should have
ended up together yeah yeah I heard that
can I direct that that question to the
audience with Emilio and Malia and Theo
thing no yeah I don't want to answer it
because if I say the wrong thing I don't
want objects thrown in my face
other ways yeah this is I'm just not
gonna participate I'm gonna plead the
fifth on this one ah man I've done
there's there's been a lot of great
scenes honestly I think the the scene in
the finale is is one of my favorites you
know it's coming up I think you guys are
really gonna love it it's such an
insight into this character and who this
guy is you know that one was a special
scene it's it's it's it was a moment man
it was a moment I think see I think the
fans really get a glimpse into not me
naked but you know maybe I mean maybe
that's coming up but I think the fans
really get to see the heart of Theo and
that's something that I'm I'm very
excited about I've got a lot more to say
about that scene after it airs yeah yeah
I wish I could tell I wish we could tell
you guys about it Linden what's our next
question well that was sort of my
question that I was thinking about
asking but so when during and this is
this is I'll start with with asking mr.
Posey when did you know in this in this
series that it was more than just a job
that it was something special was there
a moment that you went boom bingo
got it I mean I think from the second
that I book because I at that time I had
been acting for 12 years I think and I
had never done like a leading role and
so I was I was I was really excited to
to get this show and I knew that going
into it wouldn't be just a job for me it
would be kind of like finding my purpose
you know because I I don't just want to
act or be famous or anything like that I
want to I want to be I want to I want to
inspire people and and have fun and show
people that life is you know you don't
take it too seriously and just you know
just have fun and then and then when I
met dill
turn off the lights please I mean the
lights to be turned off when I met dill
and and and everything that we were
talking about before we booked the show
we were talking about moving in with
each other and and just felt really
right and it felt really cool I never
had too many buddies growing up as an
actor that were in the industry cuz I
never really related with a lot of kids
and so he and I were we were both
wearing skateboard companies he was
wearing a DVS shirt I was wearing a
Hurley shirt and so those are both like
skateboard brands and I felt like there
is a total like headbands and we were
both in bands we were both musicians and
we just had a lot in common with each
other and we were both the same exact
age and it was yeah it was it was just
it was just the greatest and I I felt
like going into it was never going to be
a job it was always going to be there
was just there was so much incentive for
me to enjoy what I was doing you know it
wasn't just work it was friendship and
finding my purpose in life and becoming
an adult and making a difference you
were the best leader yeah Dylan Dylan
was there a moment in the show that for
you you it be you realize that it was
something special one specific moment
that you went this is more than just a
normal job I mean for me it was all it
was it was never a job it was so far
especially especially from the beginning
you know I was I was a kid out of high
school who had never acted before and I
just like you know try it out
auditioning and like got this part and
met Tyler and just couldn't been more
excited to now go and experience this
and it was all so new to me and being on
a set and working as an actor it was you
know I was uh I was just winging it -
this show became my entire school you
know that I went to every day to learn
what I was doing to be on set and in
front of a camera and learn about the
you know whole process that I was in
love with
but I mean it you know I was so the this
show started that way and then and then
it always became home throughout you
know even when I got another part or
went and did something else in between
on a hiatus I just couldn't wait to come
home you know and couldn't wait to suit
up with styles again you know I get all
pumped and I get so excited that I get
to go back to Styles because I love him
so much and so wait either
that was way we couldn't wait either oh
I remember I remember you guys season
one and I was talking to both of you and
I said as the leads of this show it's
your responsibility you are the host of
the party you set the tone on the set
and we all talk about family we talk
about all this and I they did they set
the tone they made this set what it is
they created the atmosphere they created
the family they created the joy and
thank you yeah I know a lot of a lot of
shows say this but this show is true
everybody up here really likes each
other although like when when shows get
to like the seventh six seven seas and
it kind of all hate each other they
don't want to be in the same scene with
each other anymore but everybody here
and it makes me very proud of them to is
that they've all remained really good
friends and Melissa you and I have
talked about this before which is when
the show became special I know the
moments when it became special to me
what about you that same question to you
I think I think it was special along the
way but when you're reminiscing and you
realize that you've never had a bad day
on set like really when you really think
about it you've never had a bad day on
set because everyone that worked on Teen
Wolf cast and crew wanted to be there
and that that when I look back on it
that's what I feel I want to say thank
you I love Teen Wolf
thank you the best my question is you
guys have been doing this for so long is
there a
moment or a lesson that you guys are
going to take back with you even after
everything is done who wants to start I
think that's a really good one it's it's
hard to kind of comprise just everything
that we've learned into one moment but
one of the things I mean it's it's
awesome working with such talented
actors and I think one of the things
that I've learned is just to put your
all into it
that's the one thing that I see that
everyone does puts a hundred and ten
percent whether that's getting into
character whether that's showing up
early whatever it is putting you're a
hundred percent effort into something it
always pays off
so that's that's one of the things that
I think I've learned working yeah I
agree with that
working hard we're gonna hard we're
gonna hire there's no better payoff we
worked really really really hard and you
know our payoff is incredible look at
you guys yeah I think I think to the
between the culture onset and the
dynamics between everybody in the cast
and even with the fandom like you guys
have always encouraged our authenticity
and everybody who you see up here this
is very much who they are as people and
as I go out into the world after having
worked on Teen Wolf
thank you all you all encouraged all of
us to be our most authentic selves and I
think that will take everybody quite far
so and I think for me what was amazing
is we never settled and that that came
from the top down that started with Jeff
and went all the way down okay was never
good enough and we we never settled and
I think that that six years later we're
pretty much proud of every single
episode that we did so that's that's
something also to say that not many
shows make it to their hundredth episode
and so I think I speak for all of us
were very grateful yeah it's very very
grateful to be here so thank you oh yeah
yeah I kind of okay I don't want to jump
in on this as well I feel very very
fortunate and very lucky to even be
sitting here right now
and it's something I don't take for
granted and this show is kind of just
thank you I love you too like this is
like it's unreal for me this is all
still very very new just being a part of
this show just sitting here with with
these talented people just reminds me
that anything in life you know once you
make that decision it is possible it is
you you are capable of doing and
creating anything that you want and you
know this show really has reminded me of
that and each one each and every one of
you remind me of that every single day
so again to reiterate thank you
Sprayberry um I'd say the one thing that
I took away from filming was just I
learned how to be I guess light-hearted
all the time you know I learned how to
take my jobs or like how to be serious
while working but not take anything too
seriously because we've all just managed
to have so much fun the whole time no we
just we I don't think there's ever been
like a too serious moment on set no
one's lost their cool like we'll do a
scene and then and then just have fun
right after and in between and before
and that's just what made it so easy to
to work on the show for this long I
think and for everyone else as well it's
really a good thing the same man I
totally agree with you don't take
yourself too seriously
yeah yeah I feel like everyone's you
know never take yourself too seriously
would take the work seriously I feel
like we've always done that we've always
had so much fun together but also no
one's ever slacked off on set everyone's
always poured their heart into
everything we ever did and the grateful
thing - I'm gonna just echo and you know
I mean this is the first thing I ever
did again you know and like and for it
to be something so special and also
we'll just to have success and elastin
be a hundred episodes I know how rare
that is - that's not lost on me and so I
really I couldn't be more grateful for
the
and how well it did and how how much
time we all got to spend together the
hours man I mean my god
and that's and I know that this is a
special thing you know and and that and
and also I couldn't have asked for a
more special role either you know to
this day and I'm sure this will still
maintain true for the rest of my career
I'll always look back at Stiles I think
is just being my ultimate favorite I
mean just like you know it's just the
best character a guy can ask for and
it's the it's the best first thing I
could have asked for and it's just so
none of that's lost on me and so I think
going forward to I'll just always kind
of appreciate when something's you know
special like this what does it feel like
because when I was growing up we were
big Michael J Fox fans Back to the
Future was huge Stiles was Jerry Levine
yeah Isles was a guy sounds was the guy
who rode the van and with Michael J Fox
van surfing what does it feel like to
know that more people most people know
you as Stiles now not that guy in that
Michael J Fox movie well that's a trip
yeah that's a trip the first when we
were doing this you know and you showed
us the movie remember we watched it
around and we were doing a bunch of
interviews and they and it came out that
like none of them had actually seen the
movie so we I sat them down at my house
and we all watched the original Teen
Wolf together and when it was over they
all looked at me and they were like
that's that's not our show yeah I
remember I remember like loving Jerry
Levine in it and cracking up and and
getting excited to about you know there
was the version that you know since I
hadn't seen it before I kind of had
started thinking about this character
the way I saw it I had my own take on it
but uh but then I even wanted to start
like implementing a little like Jay
Levine into it I don't know I don't know
if I did or not at all
but it was just cool to yeah to be
styles and and for so many people to you
know now know him and
like him like I did you know loved him
like I did I I have one one major lesson
I learned on this show was to bring
people up whoever to find out what
people really want to do and to get them
there to help them get there and it was
really proud for me to see both Linden
and Tyler become directors this season
yeah you're gonna see their episode guys
I just just asked my own question what
was it like to direct it was the coolest
III ever since I was a kid I started
acting really young and I always kind of
would film stuff and I always I always
kind of had that aspiration and it just
felt right it felt right I really want
to start making my way towards that kind
of avenue of this business so thank you
for giving me the opportunity thank you
for trusting me you're the greatest
one thing I want to say about it though
is we when an actor says they want to
direct you the producers get kind of
worried about it we're like oh God
actor wants direct can they do it are
they gonna be alright I was up shooting
another pilot in Canada while he was
directing his episode and everyone on
set was texting me and sending pictures
of Tyler and telling me what a
phenomenal job he was doing what if my
DP my first ad my producers they were
all proudly texting me and showing me
shots and showing me pictures of Tyler
behind the camera that's the kind of
atmosphere we had on set
it wasn't who's gonna it wasn't the
actor wants to direct now it was Tyler's
gonna direct an episode it's gonna be
amazing
and that's the kind of atmosphere we had
on the show and it's a damn good episode
hey ty what's up man yeah buddy it's
been so long and I want to say that you
guys are the best actors casts and this
show is the best and I will never forget
about you guys forever thank you my
final question before as a sign of a
goodbye was the most memorable thing you
will never forget about Teen Wolf this
for everyone
the people whether it was these guys are
you guys I mean we know your name I you
know we genuinely love the fans and our
interactions with them and you know
we're all normal real people and so I
just miss everybody so much including
you guys so I'm gonna come to Comic Con
every year as a fan just kind of hang
out get drunk with you guys let's go
down look down the line Melissa what's
what's the most memorable thing for you
just how lucky we all were to find each
other
Charlie um somebody pointed this out to
me recently in it it really got to me in
a really sweet way a lot of you grew up
watching this show you know you might
have started at 13 or 14 and now you're
in your late teens or your early 20s or
whatever it doesn't matter what age you
are
but you grew up watching us just like we
grew up watching I don't know the show's
we grew up watching and you know we grew
up getting to play for you so the fact
that we've all been in each other's
lives for six or over six years that's
that's amazing that's pretty cool I mean
my man Tyler said it best it's you know
the people and and each and every one of
you and the connection the relationship
I have with everyone sitting up here you
know I know wherever we all go we're all
gonna have each other and that means the
world to me how much we laughed I don't
think I've ever laughed this much in my
life and Shelley remember when I
wouldn't we had the phone conversation
yes Jeff and I were just discussing my
entrance of the show I don't have an
audition I was very I'd whatever so I
was asked to come to a small part on
Teen Wolf and then it turned into
something bigger because Jeff is a doll
and lifesaver and he he called me and I
was at a gas station and he asked if I
wanted to stay on his Malia and I was
like will you make her funny
he's like well are you funny like I
guess we'll find out that's how I joined
the show and she is very funny Thanks
the verdicts still out but that's okay
Jeff thank you I I'm not gonna forget
Jeff Jeff I you've I think it all starts
from the top and from the tippy top to
the very bottom these people in our
lives even everybody here I mean
everything that has touched us that
involves Teen Wolf has been just so
incredible so thank you thank you now
they're gonna make me cry can I add one
thing to it to me it was watching these
kids grow up I'm not their dad and they
got perfectly good dads but I god I
couldn't be more proud of you guys I
couldn't be more proud just yeah I just
think the most memorable thing besides
every day on set filming with these guys
is I never thought I was ever gonna be
at comic-con
it's just specifically like this is
insane I just auditioned for a character
and now I'm here so I'm just every every
experience has been a ride and I'm just
thankful to be a part of something that
was just so cool so cool that's awesome
all right we can do one more quest
question it's quick thanks buddy
and don't start with this is for
everyone on the panel nice oh yeah
what's your favorite drag it out your
show has inspired me more than I can
express
and just knowing that amazing people
like you exist and can succeed in this
world without becoming corrupt this
sounds so weird
an incredible comfort for me last year
watching you all help me through my
darkest hour discovering a world of
strength and support and PAC made my own
monsters seem a little less terrifying
so when things have gotten hard for you
in your lives what got you through it
and what advice can you offer those of
us still struggling through the dark wow
this sounds like a question for you
Tyler you doing sure yeah by the way
thank you for saying that I know a
personal that is and how scary that
could be sometimes I go through a lot of
gnarly dark stuff too and what helps me
my friends my family a lot of times when
I get down to a dark point I don't want
it I don't want to do anything I don't
want to see anybody but the usually
friends and people that you love are the
only people that can pull you out and I
can't even say how many times dill has
has just helped me see the better side
of things and and be inspired by him and
I mean this this this this truly doesn't
happen a lot this little dynamic that we
all have here so this is this is really
great
and you know just just reach out you
know really talk to people
therapy is always great you know you got
to try it out see if you like it see if
it works for you but yeah just talk like
you're doing right now this is
incredible you know I I just I just
recently started coming out about all
this stuff that I got going on so I
really respect it and just keep doing
that kind of thing you know being life
isn't always supposed to be happy this
is not the way it is it doesn't really
make sense that way you know there's
supposed to be good and bad and learning
to deal with all the good and bad kind
of creates this wholeness in you and I
think that's what people are searching
for rather than happiness is just being
whole and so you got to accept the good
and the bad
know that they're all out there so
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen make some noise
here
restrooms are located inside
you